لحظات حرجه جدا عاشتها وعانتها طفله
اردنيه رصدتها كاميرا مراقبه بعد تعرضها
لحاله اختناق لكن العنايه الالهيه سخرت
لها من ينقذنا اخيرا طبيب الكويتي حديث
التخرج يعقوب العصيمي
ظهر في اللحظه المناسبه ليجري الاسعافات
الاوليه للطفله لتكتب لها حياه جديده بعده
لحظات عصيب الطبيب الكويتي مشاهدينا اصبح
حديث مواقع التواصل طبعا التي اشادت
بتصرفه الاسعافي السريع والذي تمكن من
خلاله من انقاذ الفتى رغم صعوبه الموقف
سالت عنه حكوا لي كانه يعقوب العصيمي
الكويت والله
ما شاء الله والله ما شاء الله عليهم
والله يشرف بلده
ان شاء الله الله يحفظه
لنا ما شاء الله عنه والله اسمع طبعا الكل
اخذوا بالاحضان
انت حديث تخرج واكيد مارست لكن هي لحظه ما
بين التردد وما بين انقاذها كيف جاءت انا
تخرجت وكان لازم ارجع الكويتة لكل الشباب
ارجعوا للكويت لكن انا صراحه كنت تعبان من
الاختبارات الاخيره حق كليه الطب
فقررت اني ااجل شوي رجعتي قلت اربع ثلاث
ايام ارتاح فيهم
وسبحان الله كنت طالع للسوق ابي اشتري
شنطه على اساس اشيل اغراضي واودع اربد
واودع الاردن وارجع الى ديرتي واهلي في
الكويت سبحان الله وانا ما اعرف السوق
قاعده تمشي صدفه اني سمعت صراخ ابو او شذي
فاول ما طليت سبحان الله انتبهت ان كانت
في زجاجه ماي ما كان عليه خطا اذا تنتبه
على الطاوله
فاحنا دارسين وعارفين ان غالبا واغلب
حالات الاختناق تكون بسبب غطاء
وانتبهت على الطفله كانت حاطه يدها حوالين
رقبتها اذا منتبه هذا دلاله انك كان في
اختناق
وبلش يطلع عليه وجهه يكون احمر فالحمد لله
اللي الله سخرني والحمد لله اللي الله
قادني وفضل علي ومن علي اني اكون موجود في
هذه اللحظه اني انقذ روح بشريه الحمد ما
كنت مسافر يعني سبحان الله اخرت سفرك
علشان تنقذ حياه بالفعل دكتور انت استخدمت
الهيملك
منوره الهايملك كما يقال لحتى انك تقدر
تخلص البنت الصغيره من او الطفله من حاله
الاختناق اشرح لنا اكثر لانه حتى هاي
المناوره دقيقه نوعا ما واستخدامها على
الاطفال مختلف عن استخدامها على البالغين
هذه بشكل عام تحتاج صراحه تدريب ميداني
تكون الضغط حواليه فوق السره تحديدا على
المعده الضغط اللي داخل ثم الى اعلى هذا
الشيء راح يسبب بالضغط على الرئه الضغط
على الرئه راح يولد الضغط الى اعلى على
حوالين القصبات الهوائيه فبالتالي يزال
الجسم العالق في البلعوم انا صراحه بس احب
انوه ان يعني العلامات اللي تظهر على
الحالات الاختناق هي كالتالي
في البدايه راح نشوف انه يحاول يكح يحاول
يصدرك على الشباب الاردنيين
فقالب ما راح يقدر يطلعها فممكن ينتقل
للحاله الثانيه اللي هي انه راح يحمر
وجهها او يزرق
واذا قدر الله ما تمت المساعده راح ندخل
في الغيبوبه او الاغماء ومن ثم اذا لا قدر
الله يعني ما وجد المساعده لا قدر الله
وبعيد الشر وتتحول حاله الى وفاه
[موسيقى]